[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
[Music]
welcome to let's talk to tony michael's
podcast
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central right here on youtube twitter
and twitch
[Music]
what do we have to talk about today
hmm
you know i hate i hate for everything to
be uh
so shitty to talk about on the [ __ ] list
but today on the [ __ ] list we get to
talk about actually flushing the toilet
can you believe this [ __ ]
what in the actual [ __ ] is happening
how the [ __ ] did we get in this timeline
where
a president of the united states of
america
is tearing up documents
eating them and flushing them and wiping
his ass with the constitution apparently
i don't know maybe there's a toilet
paper commercial in there somewhere
jesus christ and says good morning
hi
says patty hi y'all
good morning says robin
yoda's here lisa's here
good morning good morning all good
morning to you
oh the [ __ ] list is gonna be fun today
it is gonna be fun to round up the the
[ __ ] list
oh my god i ca you can't even make this
[ __ ] up you can't make this up
you can't i call it the [ __ ] list and
here this [ __ ] is flushing [ __ ]
down the toilet
flushing
classified
documents from the national archives
down the [ __ ] toilet
i've said before everything trump
touches turns to liquid [ __ ]
rick wilson says everything trump
touches dies but everything trump
touches turns to liquid
[ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] are we here
in this timeline the way that we are
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
that we have to sit here talking about
this [ __ ]
that a president united states would rip
up a [ __ ] document
eat it he's putting it in his [ __ ]
mouth apparently omarosa
you remember omarosa she's the one from
the apprentice the one that worked in
the white house as a staff
i believe in the communications
department i don't remember she wasn't
even there that long there was a big
ordeal about how she left and how she
got fired
but omarosa was saying how it was weird
that he was eating documents and
everyone's like oh she's [ __ ] crazy
nope
apparently not
we are in the [ __ ] timeline
in our country someone at home office
unplugged the [ __ ] national timeline
and plug that [ __ ] back in plug
it back in reset that son of a [ __ ]
this is ridiculous it really is [ __ ]
stupid
that we have to we have to do serious
[ __ ] political commentary
and pretend like it is [ __ ] normal
that a president united states would
stand in a room with staffers looking at
a piece of paper that he knew would get
him in trouble or he thought he thought
he well i don't want anyone to see this
so he rips it up in pieces and sticks it
in his [ __ ] mouth and starts eating
it
have you ever have you ever [ __ ]
looked at a document in your hand and
thought you know the best course of
action here is to rip this [ __ ] thing
up and eat it
the only other time that i've ever
[ __ ] heard or seen of someone
flushing down the toilet is in a
gangster movie when they're flushing
drugs and evidence are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me then this [ __ ] guy is on
video in front of a microphone in a
podium at his rallies talking about how
toilets don't flush good enough i can't
flush a whole file full of documents
down a [ __ ] toilet
i need the heavy flush when you're when
you're flushing boxes of documents [ __ ]
and then this dumb [ __ ] releases
a statement talking about how oh it's
normal it's normal for the national
archives to come retrieve
presidential records
and then the national archive apparently
gives a referral to the department of
justice about the handling of those
documents look if it was just normal
[ __ ] handling fine whatever yeah sure
but when he releases a statement saying
it's fake news and it's all [ __ ] you
know that [ __ ] is a hundred
percent true
that's where we're at anything that
[ __ ] said is fake news and ain't
true is the 100 [ __ ] truth that's
where we gotta start
like we have to start there
and they're still dumb [ __ ] out
there that think it's a good idea to
have this son of a [ __ ] in charge of
anything absolutely anything
absolutely [ __ ]
craziness
that we had a president united states
who was [ __ ] tearing up documents and
eating them and flushing them down the
[ __ ] toilet
and we think and we think in our history
that the smoking gun the tape the [ __ ]
that that nixon was deleting off the
tapes the recordings that he had well
that was oh my god i was egregious
jesus christ nixon looks like a shiny
[ __ ] rose at this point
those people who push nixon out of
office should be [ __ ] ashamed of
themselves
that's where the [ __ ] we're at
and there are still [ __ ] out
there in the country that are running
around you work with them you talk to
them you see them in the grocery store
that thinks it's a good idea
for this dumb [ __ ] to be in
charge of anything
anything
and of course you know the onslaught of
of the right wing is gonna say oh
liberals are so upset that someone who
doesn't rip up documents who doesn't
[ __ ] flush documents down the toilet
this is ridiculous how could you say
such egregious things about our orange
mussolini jesus it's all fake news
anyways but who doesn't flush documents
down the toilet because here's the thing
here's what they have to do they have to
say it's [ __ ] and they have to
defend it all at the same time because
they know it's [ __ ] real and the
reason why we know it's real because
he's saying it's not
like he's confirming it to us
this story comes out that he's flushing
documents and eating [ __ ] paper
and he's like nope that didn't happen
that's fake news confirmed
[ __ ] confirmed fact checked right
there he [ __ ] said he didn't do it so
there it is
he realizes that right they [ __ ] know
that right
they know that that's where you have to
have the starting point
in the narrative with this dumb
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] criminal
and you know he wasn't eating and
[ __ ] flushing documents that was you
know his [ __ ] mcdonald's order that
he was giving to someone
they already know his mcdonald's order
why would you write that down they know
what he gets from mcdonald's that fat
[ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
and especially in the situation where we
have to try to make this [ __ ] funny
you dickweed you [ __ ] come on
give us some [ __ ] leeway here
we can't even make that we can't even
make this [ __ ] up anymore you can't make
this [ __ ] up imagine standing imagine
being an interpreter
and you just listened to this
[ __ ] say to putin and putin just
told told him to be his little [ __ ] and
donald trump said i'm your little [ __ ]
in a private room with you and one other
interpreter
and you're taking [ __ ] notes and
donald trump the president united states
turns to you and says hey give me those
notes
because he knows that they step outside
that room that [ __ ] those [ __ ] notes
are part of the presidential archives
he rips them up in little pieces i'm
just snowballing here i wasn't there
but just imagine this
this is where we're at this is the [ __ ]
that we have to consider
rips up the [ __ ] notes
stuffs them in his mouth in front of
putin
and eats the documents so he can [ __ ]
them out later
while he's tweeting
and republicans are running around
thinking [ __ ]
biting somehow beholding the putin get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you stupid [ __ ] traitors
you people are [ __ ] traitors if you
still support this [ __ ] if
you're still in bed with this son of a
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] traitor
you are un-american just like mike pence
said you were [ __ ] un-american and it
was a violent insurrection it was an
attempt to overthrow the constitution of
the united states and he's hiding it
he's eating documents to hide the [ __ ]
not just january 6 but russia too
guarantee it [ __ ] guarantee it
and when the when when they write a
story about it when they find it [ __ ]
somewhere he'll [ __ ] release a
statement saying it's [ __ ] fake news
and we'll know it's [ __ ] real
that's what always pissed me off when he
would accidentally tell the truth when
he was the president united states when
he was the president for four [ __ ]
years and that [ __ ] would
accidentally stumble into the truth it
would piss me off because i was like oh
[ __ ] it's not that he was right it's not
that he was telling the truth i was like
god damn it i got tricked like my mind
my mind he'd accidentally tell the truth
you know what i'm talking about you'd he
would accidentally tell the truth right
and your mind's like well that can't be
[ __ ] true he's saying it
but here we are in this timeline
where we have to deal with the reality
of the person who these [ __ ] idiots
put in charge
and still want in charge
mind you they want him to be the speaker
of the house speaker of the house he's
gonna be our king get the [ __ ] out of
here
we have to live with the reality that
this dumb [ __ ] was tearing up
notes tearing up documents and eating
them
to destroy them
think about how [ __ ] desperate you
have to be for someone not to see that
[ __ ]
and then and then to [ __ ] about how
toilets don't flush good enough
they j they just don't flush a whole
file folder full of documents it's
ridiculous
i mean i flush and i flush and i flush
and i flush and the folder doesn't go
down
you know the staples the papers are
stapled together the paper clips kind of
hold the documents and i'm flushing and
i'm flushing and i'm flushing and i'm
flushing
you thought he was talking about his
[ __ ]
his mcdonald's [ __ ] turds nope he was
talking about documents the whole
[ __ ] time
and god knows god knows what the [ __ ]
he's talking about when he's talking
about shower heads at this point
who the [ __ ] even can tell what he's
talking about when he's talking about
the shower heads
who [ __ ] knows
it's gotta be something [ __ ] weird
something [ __ ] crazy off the wall
doubt me just wait
just [ __ ] wait you ain't gonna be
able to make this [ __ ] up
you won't be able to make this [ __ ] up
it just it's [ __ ] ridiculous
that we're standing around having these
conversations about how the former
president united states was flushing
documents down the toilet to [ __ ]
destroy them
i mean last week it was burn bags like
that makes sense like burnham yeah sure
but you're so [ __ ] desperate you're
gonna go to the mob movie type [ __ ] and
flushed our flushing [ __ ] down the
toilet
when the feds show up
come on you've seen good fellas you've
seen it
you've seen it when the feds show up to
the house
she takes the drugs and she flushes it
down the toilet
where do you think he gets this [ __ ]
he doesn't think of this himself
he's watched it somewhere
he's watched it somewhere on tv on the
boob tube
you know
where all his information and research
comes from
this [ __ ] guy this [ __ ] guy i
cannot believe that we have people in
this country that think it is a good
idea for this guy to even [ __ ] be in
charge of putting on his [ __ ] pants
in the morning
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with you
people
you people really need to get your
[ __ ] heads checked quick like fast in
a hurry we need mental health care in
this country fast quick and in a [ __ ]
hurry
you know i've been railing against
fascism for [ __ ] months now months
months a year over a year two [ __ ]
years i've been railing about fascism
and how it's at our front [ __ ]
doorstep but maybe the mental health
care is a way [ __ ] bigger need in
this country
that people can't put two and two
together with this dumb [ __ ]
and it seems as if big news is going to
drop this week
i can't figure out if this is the big
news or it's something bigger
that the national archives has sent a
referral to the department of justice to
see how trump was handling [ __ ]
documents
whether he was destroying them or not
what the [ __ ]
because mitch mcconnell came out and
said in front of a microphone said
exactly what mike pence said
to to
not in so many words but basically
trump's a [ __ ] loser he's un-american
and those people of january 6 are
[ __ ] criminals and anyone who
conspired with them needs to go to
prison
for all intents and purposes
that's what mitch mcconnell said in
front of a microphone and that
[ __ ] doesn't give anything
that's not measured
he knows he knows something that's why
he's waited until now to say it
he's waited until now to say it
and we have a lot of news that's being
suppressed
because of this [ __ ] toilet story
because of this national archives going
down and getting 15 boxes and him saying
oh it was just normal [ __ ]
i stole them in a normal capacity
they were supposed to go to the
presidential library which he's not
going to have a presidential library
it's it'll be a coloring book factory at
at best
at best it'll be a coloring book factory
jesus christ for at this point we're
gonna have burn bags uh toilets septic
tanks
and turds as [ __ ] as documents at the
presidential coloring book factory
jesus [ __ ] christ
this is real life this is [ __ ] real
life this isn't [ __ ] fake
and everyone's going ah jimbada and gas
prices
and the media can't pluck their head out
of their [ __ ] asses to realize that
joe biden
is back it's a back to normal type thing
it's back to normal type thing dumb
[ __ ] pluck your head out of your ass
and report [ __ ] the way that it needs to
be reported
this guy's not [ __ ] eating documents
and flushing them down the [ __ ]
toilet
nor is he nor is he
getting on his knees with putin
you [ __ ] idiots
pluck it out it's enough of this [ __ ]
i think gabe's going to be joining us
here in the second half of the first
hour
but i think what we should do is go
ahead
enough of the ranting
enough of the rant
get on with the shitless tony get on
with
it because we got a lot of things uh to
get to that's trending we have uh that
of course this flush gate and we have
the trucker convoy thing still going on
uh these [ __ ] fascists still talking
about this this [ __ ] made up [ __ ]
[ __ ]
up there in canada you know they're
causing chaos uh trying to make it seem
like there's an actual [ __ ] crisis
going on you know manufacture crisis is
what the right wing does now we have
this problem over in russia uh we we
also have the maggie haberman story
it's circulating around al franken's is
is trying to decide if he's gonna rerun
and we also have inflation news which
again
i i don't know why we have to keep going
over this and why the media keeps
getting this all [ __ ] around they they
getting this all [ __ ] around
but let's do it let's start the
countdown let's get into the [ __ ] list
let's go through the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends start that countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the tony michaels
podcast this is a shitless roundup where
we round up all the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends of the day
um caitlin's already trying to get my
attention about the christina bob story
i think this is that's that's one of the
stories i was saying it was suppressed i
think we're going to talk about this
story i think it's very [ __ ]
significant
i think that's very big news some of the
subpoenas that have happened in the last
few days um some of the things that are
happening in the january 6 select
committee and also what the doj is going
to do about it what they're not going to
do about it of course a lot of people
are bitching moaning and complaining
that the doj isn't saying anything
rob reiner i like you rob i like you rob
but you're way off the mark man you're
way off the mark department of justice
is not going to come out in front of a
microphone and announce anything they're
not going to why haven't why the [ __ ]
are we still doing this where we think
the department of justice is gonna come
out and [ __ ] say yep we're gonna
arrest that guy and that guy and that
guy just wait another month
no that's not what's happening god damn
it
stop with the [ __ ]
they've they've [ __ ] charged almost
800 [ __ ] 800 800 [ __ ]
11 of them with seditious conspiracy and
that investigation is ongoing and when
you do a conspiracy investigation you
continue to collect evidence and you
continue to get those people that are
wrapped up in the conspiracy to tell you
more about the conspiracy by pressure
pressuring them with charges and
superseding indictments that's what's
going to happen
mark my words in the next six months
stuart rhodes and all those oath keepers
will be added to a superseding
indictment which will indict more people
on their indictment on that superseding
indictment that is what's going to
happen
and i it's it's very unclear at this
point we know that he talked to the
january 6th select committee for six
hours and it was stuff concerning before
january 5th that's significant
everyone's like oh well why didn't he
say anything about the fifth or the
sixth because it might just might
endanger the investigation that the
department of justice is doing
so that's why the january 6 select
committee would probably forego that
testimony on the fifth and the sixth
because the fifth and the sixth is
probably when the most crimes happen for
the conspiracy where they were acting
and who they were acting with
so calm the [ __ ] down calm the [ __ ] down
with the department of justice [ __ ]
they're getting there trust me
you can see it you can see it in who
they're charging and when they're
charging them
and also the january 6 select committee
is collecting mountains of [ __ ]
evidence
mountains of [ __ ] i mean they're
having to tape it together and [ __ ]
sift through a bunch of septic tanks to
find it but you know they're getting
there
[ __ ] me
it's ridiculous
but everyone needs to just settle down
because here's the thing politically you
want to know about the 2022 midterms how
[ __ ] sweet would it be how [ __ ]
sweet would it be for these [ __ ] gq
peers to pick a bunch of trump humping
fools to be their candidates in the
general election for or in the midterm
huh how [ __ ] sweet would it be for
them to tie themselves to donald trump
100
all [ __ ] year
and then all the [ __ ] hammer drops in
the fall huh how [ __ ] sweet would
that be you want politics there's
politics i'm always talking about how
politics and government are separate
well let's do that thing
a [ __ ] i would i would love for
democrats to run all around the country
about a bunch of people who were
propping up criminals
look what they did look they tried to
overturn the constitution in the united
states they're [ __ ] traitors
seditious conspiracy members of congress
oh well
it might be easy to beat a [ __ ]
candidate for congress who is charged
with seditious conspiracy to overturn
the constitution of the united states
come on
think about it
the republicans are the ones who wanted
this [ __ ] to be political in the first
place
[ __ ] democrats wanted the 911 style
commission for for weeks
for weeks they wanted the 911 style
commission they passed it in the house
republicans didn't want it in the senate
because they wanted the political fight
that's what they wanted that's what they
wanted because they thought they would
win that fight because they think
democrats liberals moderates people in
the democratic party tent are a bunch of
[ __ ] that's what they think and i
think they're wrong dead [ __ ] wrong
they think
they think merrick garland is a squish
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
merrick garland ain't making the
decisions on the prosecutions in the
first place almost 800 indictments 800
people indicted in the dec by the dc
united states attorney
right
got it the the u.s attorney in the dc
district has charged almost 800 people
including 11 people with seditious
conspiracy
which is ongoing and will probably have
superseding indictments you're going to
hear that word a lot
superseding indictments
conspiracy you're going to hear those
words
over and over and over again in the next
six months
and it's going to take a little bit but
you know maybe we want it to take a
little bit
maybe it would be nice to take a little
bit
i don't know i'm just saying politically
i would if i was running for congress
and my opponent was
was out on bail
for uh or or locked up in a dc jail
versus seditious conspiracy
because they helped [ __ ] uh uh
deal a pardon for their [ __ ] for
their actions to overturn the government
of the united states and commit a cheeto
dust kangaroo coup and you're tied up in
that conspiracy yeah that's who i want
to run against
i'm just saying if i had a choice
that's who i'd want to run against and
that might happen in a few of these
districts
kaelin kaelin's not going to give up on
this christina bob i'm going to get to
the christina bob thing
send me the link
she's probably
send me the link i'll do the christina
bob thing because i think it is
significant we've seen yesterday
see if i can find it here we seen
yesterday uh where there was a report
that christina bob may have had
something to do
with
there we go seizing voting machines
she was writing orders
um if you guys don't know who christina
bob is they keep okay i'm gonna do the
christina bob thing here
christina bob let's make this bigger
there we go because i think this is
actually really significant news
um
and the reason why
is because this is part of the seditious
conspiracy
this is the part of the conspiracy to
overturn the our vote
um spiro agnew
spear agnos ghost reported this breaking
metadata on the earliest known draft
copy of trump's executive order to seize
voting machines says the document
creator
and and here spiro agnew says onn
reporter which she is now currently an
onn reporter but she hasn't always been
is christina bob
well known as an off the charts trump
sycophant who was at the willard hotel
war room on the fifth and the sixth
um as a caitlyn here you go kaylin
points out here she likes to eat cookies
in the willard hotel room while engaging
in filthy [ __ ] seditious conspiracy
to overthrow the will of the people in a
freedom free and fair election [ __ ] her
and here she is let's zoom this in there
she is christina bob
now a lot of people think she's an oan
reporter which she is now but she hasn't
always been
she's not always been a [ __ ] oan
reporter
she was also involved in the fraud it
the the arizona [ __ ] with cyber
ninjas trying to overthrow an election
there
and the word is overthrow not overturned
they're trying to overthrow our
government that's what they're
continuing to do all around the country
the good news is we have a lot of
democratic lawyers that are standing in
their [ __ ] way
and continue to stand in our way now if
you look here in this picture who is
this guy who's this guy john eastman
where do we know that [ __ ] from
well we know john eastman from the
powerpoint and the memo of how to commit
a cheeto dust kangaroo coup and we are
getting more and more clear
on what the what this uh alternative
slate the fraud slate of electors we're
going to do
and then we see [ __ ] grandpa poopy or
grandpa farty mcshardy excuse me i get
them mixed up a few times you know when
you're connected at the mouth and then
and the
you know what you know it's hard to not
confuse these two
rudy giuliani's sitting here at the
table you know going you know it looks
like he's trying to figure out how to
work his [ __ ] cell phone here
and christina bob
is eating [ __ ] cookies
like it's nothing you know it's just
another day of overthrowing the united
states government no big [ __ ] deal
now what you don't know about christina
bob and what a lot of people don't know
about christina bob is christina bob
was a government official for the
department of homeland security are you
listening
she's a former military officer
she's no she's not just some [ __ ]
dumb reporter for oann she's not
she knows what the [ __ ] she's doing
she's also a [ __ ] lawyer
and a [ __ ] traitor to her country
because she's not taking just one oath
when she was with with the military
she's taken another oath when she was
when she was sworn in at the department
of homeland security and she took
another [ __ ] oath when she became a
goddamn lawyer and entered the bar
and here she is eating cookies
overturning the constitution of the
united states wiping her [ __ ] ass
with it
planning to
maybe flush it down the [ __ ] toilet
they like to flush things down the
documents down the [ __ ] toilet
apparently
but christina bob is not just some
[ __ ] reporter with oann
christina bob didn't go to oann until
the 2020 election
until about june i think it was i don't
know the exact date but it's somewhere
june or july in 2020 is when she went
over to oann to spread propaganda before
that she was with let me say it again
the department of homeland security
did you hear department of homeland
security
a former military officer a lawyer
a licensed lawyer
she's significant in this plot 100 toe
she's significant and if you don't think
her role at oan is significant too it is
that's where the propaganda came from
that's how they spread the big lie that
was the [ __ ] plan the whole goddamn
time is if he lost they would try to
[ __ ] spread propaganda to make the
country just make him president
enters john eastman and grandpa farty
mcshardy rudy giuliani
you can call this a war room if you want
at the willard hotel
but if this is a war room this is the
cheeto confederacy
trying to overturn our vote
they were trying to steal our election
you know the stop the steal [ __ ]
they were stealing it it's always
projection with these [ __ ]
always
so don't get twisted up about who
christina bob is
she's not just some dumb oan reporter
that doesn't know what she's doing and
just takes orders
she strategically placed at oan for a
[ __ ] reason when she was placed there
for the reason that she was replaced
she was with oan and
right here eating cookies
yup that's right she was with
she's just a lowly old reporter in the
war room at the willard hotel trying to
overthrow the constitution of the united
states
give me a [ __ ] break
and she needs to get paid more attention
to and quick
because my guess is she knows a lot of
[ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ]
about this conspiracy to overthrow the
constitution of the united states
and i'm sure i'm sure the department of
justice
is looking into it
because we see
that they know that the memo that was
written
to unplug machines or seize the machine
so that way they could [ __ ] overthrow
the government
that way no one could question the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopypants
the orange mussolini jesus himself
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
all right
we'll come back to christina bob i'm
sure in the future
in the future we will come back to
christina bob
let's go to the treaty tweets and the
trendy trends here now of course you
know
maggie haberman's story she's number 10.
maggie writes an exclusive here
of trump communicating with kim jong-un
apparently these two
bros are still having a bromance
they still love each other well you know
i i wouldn't be opposed to him going on
his first date or i guess it would be a
second date
with kim jong-un in north korea would
you
i mean i'm all for it hell i'd pay for
the ticket let's do that let's put
enough [ __ ] scratch together let's do
a gofundme
to send grandpa poopypants to go have a
a love vacation with this [ __ ] with
this bromance out in north korea
what the [ __ ] is he still talking to
this guy for
i thought they broke up didn't they
break up didn't we see this in the
[ __ ] variety or whatever the [ __ ]
tabloids are they broke up they don't
like each other hey look who's popping
in here
good morning
good morning yeah
say hi to gabe everybody hi hi hi hi we
just got off the christina bob um story
and that now we're now we're focusing in
on uh the the great headline writer
maggie haberman
the last week she's been
trash because she was writing really
shitty headlines which
i don't think she actually writes the
headlines for her stories i'm not sure
exactly how that works but but um
here the story is that she's got here
with axios is that um apparently
donald trump misses his lover kim
jong-un and they're still um
in this little spat back and forth they
want to
you know they want to
continue their bromance what do you
think about this
it's not
it's not surprising
right
okay yeah i do want to kind of go on i
just want to get onto a soapbox for a
second yeah sure
uh journalists writers who do this
i
i don't have that much of an
appreciation for right because
you've got you mean this story in
particular these types of stories well
it's these types of stories where all of
a sudden they drop this news in a book
meanwhile they ignored everything that
was happening during the presidency to
reveal these details right like this so
what you're saying is is that they've
concealed this so that way they can sell
a book right exactly if you look at what
happened during the pandemic you know
you've got uh
uh
the
the details of what trump was doing
behind the scenes for covid wasn't
released until it was in the book
right right and so when i see like it's
great you know go get yours or whatever
try to you know get your money but at
the same time like if you're not
revealing details about something in the
presidency that affects millions of
people
then there's something to be said there
and i don't
i think what you're saying and and i
hear you're saying is it a free press
when they're doing that like are they
skating their responsibility of actually
reporting stories
right well right i mean and so when i
say right and so when i see this stuff i
look at i'm like okay great you were
able to get inside scoop into something
that you know if someone is trying to
flush down classified documents or
confidential documents any documents any
document right like the fact that that
is being done is just ludicrous but if
it's a president who's trying to do that
and you have not reported on it
and you know it yeah you know i have a
big issue with that and the same thing
is that again of like what happened
during covet where it's like oh yeah
well this and these details were
revealed about tests is that why bob
woodward is trending is that why because
that's awesome i don't know bob woodward
was trending i put him on the list um
and i think that maybe that's why
because bob woodward did a lot of those
interviews with trump in january
february and march and if he
where he was saying the exact opposite
of what he was saying in public because
he didn't want his supporters to know
what he actually felt right i mean he's
lies to these people he's not talking to
us
but in a way it is lying because you're
withholding the truth right you know it
and you now have said to yourself i'm
going to hold back these details because
it's later going to go in a book i'm
going to sell for money right and that's
not going to be impressed right right i
mean i'm not going to be able to sell
that book because it's already been
released so there's nothing maybe like
you know there's not going to be no
substance of juicy details no gossip
nothing that's going to lure a reader in
to say i will buy that book
but then you have a year months later
and they're like oh hey by the way they
were doing this thing well why the [ __ ]
weren't you reporting on it when you had
all these uh
these conversations in private
well that's that's because these details
are worth a lot of [ __ ] profit right
you know and that's maybe the problem
that we have right now with the press
and this trump loop right like they they
report on [ __ ] with biden like this
inflation thing they're losing their
minds over inflation like well of course
we have heavy inflation we came out of a
[ __ ] manufacturing and production
[ __ ] depression basically right
during covet like of course the number
is gonna be [ __ ] high it's gonna be
good like it it it is gonna be high and
yes we do have inflation but there was
things that democrats in the present
united states did to try to to keep that
under control which was the inflation
protection with the child tax credit now
not all americans were going to receive
inflation are that inflation protection
but the idea was to give american
families
a flush of money so that way it could
spread around that's how the economy
works when people have money they spend
it when they spend it it helps you it
helps me you know that's how an economy
works and and because the economy is
heated because we were in this
production um
and really
uh a demand depression now we have high
demand it's heated but and it's not easy
for the american people
when they have the incomes that they
have but this is why we have to have all
these conversations about who are we
going to put in government to make sure
that when this [ __ ] arises that
someone's there to [ __ ] do the right
thing not flush documents down the
[ __ ] toilet right
like how dumb do you have to be to think
you can flush a document down a toilet
and it's not gonna [ __ ] bring [ __ ]
back up at you right like figuratively
and literally like it's gonna back up
the toilet and you're gonna have to
[ __ ] put a snake down there and
[ __ ] pull out it and then they're
gonna say why why is all this paper here
and they're like don't worry about it
don't worry about it you know those
signs that say like do not flush down
female hygienic products uh you know
like uh disposable wipes or paper now
sign makers have to add classified
documents to that list because that's a
it's whenever you
whenever you see those signs where it's
like don't do this thing right in this
area it's because somebody did that
right right they didn't think they had
to make a sign or a warning or a label
before that and then somebody didn't
getting in the oval office [ __ ]
there's going to be a sign oh yeah mr
president mrs president
you know madame president whatever
whatever it would say
please do not flush classified doc
classified documents do not go here you
think there's gonna be like i think
there's gonna
i'm just saying like maybe there's gonna
be an image that comes out shortly where
assignment says do not flush classified
documents sounds like sounds like
someone might have found a video
somewhere on the obscure internet i
don't know this is crazy because we were
talking about this this morning right um
when this story broke because we heard
the story about the 15 boxes down at
mar-a-lago on the national archives and
apparently national archives has done
some kind of referral to department of
justice right over the handling of these
documents which is not good for trump or
anyone else who [ __ ] helped him with
whatever they did with these documents
right and and of course this [ __ ]
idiot you sent me this statement um and
and if you want you can put it up here
we'll look at it
i'll show the statement because i think
it's significant and the reason why is
because number one he didn't write it
number two
number two he directed someone to say
certain things in that thing about fake
news and all this [ __ ] and i'm said
earlier we you have to start when he
says this is fake news and it's not real
you have to start with okay that's the
truth right literally that's where we
start if there is denial from him
the assumption 100 of the time because
it ends up being true is that it is
actually real news right well i was even
saying earlier that sometimes like when
he fell when he accidentally told the
truth you know because he accidentally
tells the truth sometimes right right
right i i would be it would kind of mind
[ __ ] me because i'm like wait a second
that's actually true but he's saying
it gets you all [ __ ] up because he
literally he just can't help it he can't
help himself but to admit through
projection right exactly about these
this [ __ ] [ __ ] it's absolutely
insanity
and i i mean um you posted the picture
the other day uh
apparently is what these boxes were
outside the white house is that
confirmed that that that's the the
documents and the boxes that were taken
tomorrow
i don't know if that's confirmed that
those are the boxes because it looks
like those were i mean it could have
been uh i just saw that and i was like
oh this is i mean it certainly looks
like more than 15 boxes that's what i
was going to say right it's a lot more
than 15. now to be fair some of them
might be like personal possessions and
the national archives had to go down and
sort through a bunch of [ __ ] in the
attic of that [ __ ] run down golf club
that he's got down down in south florida
you know knock the dust off of them and
figure out which ones are which
right i mean like i would you know i
i feel i do have uh a little bit of
uh remorse for the uh
and like
sympathy for
the the national archives people who
actually have to go through that stuff
because i was chatting with you this
morning and i'm like well i'm already
as i'm already in the in the process of
writing a sketch about
the things that they found lo and behold
i get a new detail which is that this
dumb [ __ ] decided that he was going to
try to flush down actual papers down the
toilet
so i was like i you know again it's one
of those things where i look at i'm like
oh can you guys
uh
[Music]
just stop writing this stuff for me
because you're
right you're [ __ ] it all up yeah i
like i'm adding little details here and
there of like possible things and then
you go and just dump this [ __ ] on me and
tell me that you literally literally
yeah
uh yes well and i told you you got to
take it to a 30. like we thought like 18
or 20 is the level but right now with
with the [ __ ] that's coming out and the
[ __ ] that will come out
because this isn't gonna stop this [ __ ]
isn't gonna stop it isn't gonna stop
getting worse and it's going to get much
worse than this we're going to go what
in the actual [ __ ]
i mean
omarosa is trending too
right because omarosa they're like i saw
someone sweet this morning that was like
man she warned everyone i guess in her
[ __ ] book she said this right yeah
she she said all this stuff she she gave
a warning and no one listened to it
because they're like oh it's omarosa and
apprentice and blah blah blah she's
crazy there's no way this is true okay
well
well we live in a different [ __ ]
timeline i mean it just this is what we
have to deal with yeah
okay here's the omarosa timeline here
are the thread right let's see what we
got
uh
dude is there a video of her saying it
somewhere uh i do look here we are hey i
didn't see a video but what i did see
was a uh snapshot somebody took a
screenshot from the book
okay well here's amy uh in her new
memoir unhinged the former white house
advisor omarosa claims she
once saw president donald trump eat a
piece of paper
in the oval office which is [ __ ]
weird
yeah i mean
have you ever looked at a piece of paper
and you're like mmm yummy delicious what
you know it's definitely a new source of
fiber you know
but what i will say is when i
when i
whenever i've seen someone eat a piece
of paper it's always been in some movie
and it's always a gag
like you know maybe make some gag but it
was always a gag like a joke that they
were like disposing of the evidence and
so they were like what are you doing
right so what there is a movie with that
what what did it move
i was talking about earlier about the
good fellas when the feds come to the
house and she's flushing the drugs down
the toilet right
uh what movie is that i know what you're
talking about they stick the paper in
their mouth i know uh
you know that's a good question i know
in liar liar he stuffs paper in his
mouth he doesn't eat it
um
is that what it is
yeah okay well that may be like if i i'm
also finding a gif of jimmy fallon as
trump eating piece of paper so
it was a thing this is but this is not
this is from a while ago i would imagine
right it's probably is this the uh is
this the screenshot
here
yeah yeah that's the one
okay it says others could be truly gone
forever and i think she's talking about
documents is that what she's talking
about here in 2018 omarosa shared her
book unhinged but she revealed
shooting swallowed a note
after a meeting with michael cohen what
the [ __ ]
right
so this is what she's writing in her
book yeah
and this is the an excerpt um explains
because trump's notorious germaphobia so
that's what she's saying is he's a
germaphobe which is insane to think that
you would if you're a germaphobe you
would eat something
well
see i don't actually think he's a
germaphobe right right you know i don't
think i think he's like i don't want
people this guy the guy's been peed on i
doubt he's a german right right he's
like i don't i don't want the peasants
to touch me right right exactly i don't
want peasant juice on me whatever
whatever whatever this [ __ ] guy
thinks that's what it is it ain't a
germaphobe you know he's like ah i don't
want the peasants to touch me and you
know that
i'm not going to shake the peasant's
hand kind of [ __ ]
um let's see and if he does he does the
whole like he does the arm pull or
he shakes the hand and then
then he uh he yanks him in real quick oh
yeah yeah yeah i've seen that because he
doesn't know how to shake a hand right
right right he doesn't know yeah he's
like oh this is an alpha male move and
it's like right right
is this the gift yeah here we go there
we go that's it
the attorney general should question
omarosa another trump aide's under oath
america can't have the is present eating
and flushing national documents where
the [ __ ] is this from he is actually
trump and he's what is he doing is this
gotta be from years ago i would oh [ __ ]
like whenever that came out i mean
because
uh
oh jesus christ i don't know when this
was uploaded but oh my god how the [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] do we live in this
timeline please please someone reset the
timeline at home office this is getting
[ __ ] ridiculous
is there a vid i know she went on a
media tour
um
about the book
and it was a big deal because remember
she got sued they tried to sue her they
tried to stop it and they could they
couldn't stop the book
right
and it probably might be this reason why
they wanted to stop the book now she was
on big brother here here's some clips of
her on big brother um and you know they
were worried about that too that what
she would reveal in the big brother
house because you know it's all live
they don't have you know they know it's
not scripted or anything they can't
control what they say
and a lot of the [ __ ] that she would say
would be heard
um would be revealed to the public let's
see um
is this the same that's the same
screenshot i'm just looking to see if
there's a video does anyone know if
there's a video out there of omarosa
let's go to videos here
i've her you know saying
[ __ ] about this book because i know she
she had to have done a book tour right
no i would imagine she yeah there's no
way that she didn't i mean that's a
pretty high profile thing to you know
leaves she
leaving that administration especially
she was was she one of the first people
i know she was one in like the first
kind of round or so
um
but i wouldn't be surprised
so it looks like there's a clip from don
lemon show on cnn
um of them talking about it but not
actually her
okay well but it's just [ __ ] crazy
that we have to even discuss this [ __ ]
that they're [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
documents and i i proposed earlier
because you remember when he went and
met putin the only people in the room oh
you know what the movie's from what's
that sorry the scene of eating the paper
yeah it's the red dragon
oh yes he's eating this
[Music]
yes that's right
that's that's one that's a movie that is
one of my favorite movies with uh
phillip seymour hoffman in it he plays
such a great character in that right
because he expects to send that video
out in a second
[Laughter]
everyone be looking for that on twitter
speaking of tweets on twitter this
morning you um you had a good one let me
let me find it here
um now you redid it even though i redid
it for like accuracy purposes you know
yeah accuracy you you're just scared of
these fact checkers that's all it is
listen i'm terrified i just keep getting
you know
who who uh
tell the audience who who fact check
your statement again who was the uh oh
uh it's uh
checkyourfact.com it's a daily wire and
maybe some of you know who daley wire is
because that's ben shapiro and uh matt
walsh that's that group um
why why would they have a fact-checking
website do you think i don't know to add
legitimacy of their organization
you're saying what they would what they
i mean they actually do report they you
know they do fact check and they have it
so i don't know if it's as a means of
like uh adding legitimacy to their group
or if it has to do with the fact of like
you know just having articles where
you know that it backs them up
you know that's what i think it is is
that old people are saying type [ __ ]
here's here's here's gabe's tweet i'll
i'll i'll let you explain it here yeah
so uh if anyone's a tiger king fan then
you'll understand who the [ __ ] isn't who
the [ __ ] isn't uh well so you've got uh
trump's white house documents carol
baskin's husband
and they can both be found in the septic
tank if
[ __ ] carol baskin have you seen have
you seen the second season and i've i
watched a few episodes
of the second season and i'm like this
[ __ ] is bananas so this is the second
season is good but the the one that the
i don't know if it's a mini series or if
it's like an extension but the doc antle
story where they tell about doc oh my
god i don't you gotta go watch that dude
you gotta go watch that one
so there's [ __ ] yeah that's i didn't
yeah there's a second season of tiger
king and then there's like doc antle
tiger king type thing and i think it's i
don't know three or four episodes so
it's a couple two or three hours long
gotcha well there's also uh there's also
the there's two
possibly mini series there was one with
nicholas cage and and then he was like
i'm not doing anymore because it's not
relevant and then there's the one with
uh kate mckinnon
and others where oh you're talking about
where they're gonna do the movie or
whatever it's a it's a show it's uh joe
versus carol i think it's what it's
called uh and they filmed it so is it
actually about them and it's it's parody
or is it like based on the true events
it's based on it's a it's a drama from
what i understand uh and it's based on
the events or at least you know the
events that we we've we know or at least
have been revealed um but yeah it's the
it's
them the two between them they're feud
them going at each other right but you
know the best part about this whole
[ __ ] stupid story about him eating
and flushing documents is tiger king is
back in the timeline again we get tiger
gabe brings tiger king right back in i
mean he was recently he was he was
brought in the timeline a week or two
ago because his 22-year sentence was 21
years so you know yeah well that's part
of the um the second season where his
lawyers are trying to get a resentencing
hearing right and and they did get it
apparently and he got reduced one year
um
do you think do you think joe is guilty
do you think he's guilty
i mean
i mean you watch the [ __ ] first
series come on yeah yeah yeah he i mean
you know you're hiring me do you think
he burned the zoo the the the alligator
pit or whatever it is do you think he
burned that do you think he burned it
like they like some claim
i don't do i remember that wait yeah
well yeah
and then it burnt down and he accused
the documentary maker uh what's his name
oh that's right yeah yeah yeah i'm going
to go back and re-watch it you got to
re-watch tiger king every six months to
stay up with this stuff yeah dude
remember remember when he was like i
will not financially recover from this
exactly all of those things were like
oops it went up all the footage all this
and that like it's all stuff that i
guarantee was on some insurance claim
you know right and they're
well
i mean i mean you know it's kind of like
when i was watching the show right
because we're talking about the
beginning of the pandemic when that
tiger king started and netflix hit it
big yeah that series airing at that time
like there could be no better timing for
a netflix here because i mean it
probably would have been popular but
there's no way it would be as as known
right now as it is because of when it
comes oh yeah you know i mean it was
millions of people sitting at home and
having to watch tv right i mean it was
i remember i was on i was on set uh and
i was filming i was doing a film and uh
somebody sent me the trailer because it
was it was like as things it was the
beginning of march right and everyone's
like oh uh i don't know and people like
leaving going home to their families and
stuff i mean while we're on set trying
to finish this fight the entire country
is freaking out right yeah cause san
francisco shuts down the nba
they they cancel everything right they
just call it all off yeah so i'm on set
and everyone's like oh well this like
this pa ended up going home and they
were freaked out so we got us up for
this and we got a sub for this and i was
like what the [ __ ] is going on this is
insane and then somebody sent me this
trailer for tiger king and i was like
whoa this looks nuts and then like two
days later they're like hey by the way
everything's shutting down and then
tiger king comes out and it was like
man
[ __ ] is crazy right now in real life
and enjoy someone else's pain and misery
obviously you know what you know
we're talking about these flushing
documents and all this [ __ ] eating
documents like literally
we had tiger king as the [ __ ]
president of the united states like we
probably would have been better off for
four years of having joe exotic be our
president literally that
i mean they were trying to get him to be
and even in the second even in the
second season they they touched on that
the whole like those guys were at the
january 16th
rally they were trying to get trump to
party they left but the fact that they
had raised all this money they flew
private they put the banners on the
buses they got this they got that like
you know he's trying to get this guy to
run for president which is insane uh
especially because
uh he
he's just dude tiger king joke
exotic is such a mess man a mess a
message
like like next to hot mess in the
dictionary there's the headshot
of joe exotic and i'm not talking like
his mugshot i'm talking about him on the
[ __ ] tiger you know where he's got
like the
right yeah i mean when he was like oh
yeah you know what sells really well the
leopard uh right yeah underwear you know
yeah and you're like why would a [ __ ]
like
all places i'm gonna find and buy other
underwear especially like someone with a
an animal print on it i'm gonna go to
this
sanctuary as he called it or whatever uh
no i i'm okay you know even though he
did say it was a hot selling adam which
i'm like man i guess there's some
[ __ ] weird people out there well you
know from this guy this this story is
crazy i i'm gonna do the uh don jr did
you see because we talked about midas
touch yesterday did you see midas touch
also entered the chat with tucker and
don jr i saw that yeah i got an email
this morning from parlor from my troll
account
um they're talking about it over there
too they're sending emails out over
there too so oh you know i i wish you
could join us for the uh
don jr
but don't worry i will say this
potentially maybe possibly probably
a video
is coming out with a i may have had a
facetime call with don jr again oh okay
even though i told him never to call me
back he
he keeps going
does he did do you block his number and
he gets a new burner number or what
what's the yeah pretty somehow you know
i'm also like i feel like kind of bad
for him because he's got like right now
to talk to you know
well you can't you can't call her dog to
his dad for sure right i mean he's busy
flushing papers down the toilet so
you know he's got a mouth full of
documents he calls me and i just got to
say
hey man you know what's going on but in
this call he uh was defending joe rogan
words
we'll see how that goes we'll we'll see
well we'll be looking for that on the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
thanks thanks for stopping by gabe we'll
see you tomorrow hang out hang out after
the break we'll talk about the john du
junior video right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
and the shitless roundup where we round
up all the sweetie tweets and the trendy
trends i promised you
i promised you some don jr booger sugar
junior content and boy do we have it
here
um but you guys seen our little rant
yesterday with the um let's let's make
this a little bigger ariel okay
you seen our rant yesterday about minus
touch and um
how the the right-wing media is accusing
them
of uh
being responsible for the the downfall
rogan as if midas touch put the n-word
in in
in rogan's mouth or some [ __ ] and i'm
not sure how they you know are equating
this but don junior talked about it
what's what i think is funny and in all
fairness and all disclosures you
right-wing cup alpha cucks out there
and i partnered with minus touch um on
an interview with stuart rhodes uh a
strange ex-wife and his estranged son
you guys should go watch that interview
it's episode number 69 on the youtube
channel don't forget to subscribe while
we're talking about that go subscribe to
youtube channel and you can watch that
and that interview over there
so in full disclosure i'm part of the
cabal
you've been caballed
[ __ ] jesus
but they won't even say mind as touch
like they have trouble saying it and i
don't know if it's because it's spelled
correctly they keep saying it's spelled
wrong i'm going to show you a clip here
where they say it's spelled wrong it's
not spelled wrong it's spelled correctly
the midas touch like
the midas car auto like tire lube and
tune thing that's spelled differently
like you [ __ ] boneheads can't even
figure this out it's [ __ ] worthless
but here we go here's here's here's old
donnie booger sugar junior here
uh patriot takes opposed to this it says
joe rogan's literally quoting someone
else using the n-word and talking about
it okay
so there's a difference in the context
jew baden oh my god donald trump jr
defends joe rogan using the n word of
course he defends him using the n word
what else would you expect
let's listen to the [ __ ] bonehead
well guys today we're going to talk joe
rogan and the controversy uh surrounding
uh really what first off do you [ __ ]
hate that he starts every video with
well guys well guys well guys
well guys
well guys like dude you just you don't
have to say that part just start
you don't have to say well guys
you'd be like me coming to my show well
guys today is monday and well guys and
like and get the [ __ ] out of here
appears to me very clearly to be the
left's attempted cancellation of him
right he's gotten too much power what's
funny here is he's going to go on to say
that they want to cancel
they want to cancel the people that are
trying to cancel joe rogan because he
said the n word and canceled himself get
the [ __ ] out of here he's gotten too big
an audience he doesn't just blindly
follow the narrative and therefore
he must be eliminated notice that the
people are doing it it's pretty clear
that it's literally a democrat super pac
if you see that there's there's where he
says it's a democrat super pac
right
that's what they're saying it's a
democrat super pac because they can't
get the story straight they don't got
their facts right
right i mean it's patriot takes which is
has a pack um and then midas touch has a
pack
they are a pack they don't hide it
they're right out in the open jesus
christ they went on a [ __ ] youtube
video with dave portnoy with bar store
sports that [ __ ] alpha cuck
and they talked and had a conversation
about it and told them exactly what they
do
with patriot takes like they told them
right out in the open it's not like
they're trying to hide this [ __ ] patriot
takes on their [ __ ] twitter profile
page it says partnering with midas touch
it's not like it's [ __ ] hidden
you [ __ ] people are you [ __ ]
people are dumb you're [ __ ] dumb if
there was some kind of cabal or some
[ __ ] to take down joe rogan don't you
think they wouldn't advertise it on
their [ __ ] twitter profile you stupid
[ __ ] but he can't even say the word
midas touch and here's why because they
know they know what's gonna happen
they know what's gonna happen when they
say this you think minus touch is big
now you think they're big now because i
know a lot of you guys are midas fans
out there ladies a lot of the people
here have midas in front of their name
midas lisa midas mj
a lot of you guys love midas minus touch
and and the mizellas brothers and pop
michael popock
uh the the the guys over zoomed in
jack and aaron i mean you guys
everyone follows and likes and watches
their podcast uh pays attention to their
podcast network like kremlin files
and here we are they can't he can't say
the word out loud because he knows what
will happen
well let's listen to this [ __ ] idiot
and the company that works with them
that went and found clips of him
uh saying and that's the other thing a
company that works with what are you
talking it's a twitter account you dumb
[ __ ] a company i mean i guess
yeah they have legal papers filed but
it's not like there's a
[ __ ] office building somewhere with
30 people in it or something
people really are [ __ ] stupid
saying a bad word a bad word just a bad
word saying that bad word like not a bad
word a bad word is like [ __ ] or [ __ ] or
[ __ ] or [ __ ] those are bad words
cursing it at someone he's literally
cursing it at someone you know he wasn't
saying son of a you're a son of a [ __ ]
he was saying like he stubbed his toes
son of a [ __ ] it's different really
quoting
someone else using the word and talking
about it okay so there's a difference
and there's a context that no one seems
have any interest in talking about
certainly not um wait a second i'm
noticing here in the uh commons
um mj says um is that a crack pipe dead
center under the flag
no i i think you're talking about um i
think you're talking about this this
thing right here is that what you're
talking about
that that and veteran yoda said it looks
like a glass prostate massager
i'm not sure what the [ __ ] that is i
think you guys are right you guys are
onto something here [ __ ] this video
let's look let's evaluate what the
hell's behind him you notice what's
never on the bookshelves behind don jr
like ever
on the book shelves behind don jr
there's never one [ __ ] book not even
the bible like he can't even figure out
how to stick a bible on the shelves to
[ __ ] you know trumpet to these
goddamn christians
there's never a [ __ ] book on the
bookshelves and it's always these
[ __ ] dollar store picture frames
right
like they act like they're [ __ ] rich
and [ __ ] but these picture frames are
all [ __ ]
dollar store picture frames and then who
the [ __ ] flag is this
who in the [ __ ] in their family has ever
served none of them
who did they steal this from
did they steal this from the [ __ ]
white house i'm just wondering i don't
know whose it is
someone might want to zoom in and find
out who the [ __ ] flag this is so they
can get it back
he probably [ __ ] swiped it somewhere
[ __ ]
anyways you know we'll digress on the
[ __ ] on the sec the glass sex toy
here and the whatever that is
and i mean uh it's a massager sorry i
didn't mean to
the people who are trying to cancel but
the answer is really this guy's you
never
cave to the mob you
what
so is it is it three brothers that are
doing this or is it the mob
there can't be this pitchfork mob and
then it's only three brothers
orchestrating this do you follow this
[ __ ] do you see what they're do you see
the [ __ ] that they spread and they
how these people believe this [ __ ]
garbage is christ give them a single
inch they could not care less about your
apology i promise you so we gotta stand
with joe rogan then again i don't know
joe uh i don't have the obligatory stuff
joe doesn't know you either he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about you donny hopefully
you see getting thrown up there i've
never been on the podcast but that's
because you're a little [ __ ] and he
doesn't want you on the podcast because
you're a [ __ ] coke head and you
couldn't [ __ ] predict what the [ __ ]
you would say or do you dumb [ __ ]
i believe in free speech i believe in
our ability to say something and not
only if it's what they want to say you
know and they definitely don't want
other people simply
get people cancelled okay i mean other
than mine is touch he definitely wants
to cancel mine as dutch he we should
definitely do that so if you think
he is in danger
just think what they can do to you or
your loved ones for not complying with
their desires this is [ __ ] craziness
minus touch brett mizellis is posting
[ __ ]
audio clips of people threatening him
of course you know brett og gangster
over there brett mizelis he [ __ ]
claps back at this guy on the phone says
he's your daddy there's your daddy there
we played the video we played the audio
clip yesterday a brett handing this
[ __ ] guy his ass
wouldn't you love to listen to brett
mizella's hand don jr is it you know he
[ __ ] would oh you know he [ __ ]
would you know he'd hand him his [ __ ]
ass
he's [ __ ] gay so number one
don't let it happen number two
don't apologize do you notice let me
line it back here look look at it look
at this here number one this
this thing here
fits perfectly in here but you see how
he's looking down this guy has to have
notes you remember how they're always
like oh you [ __ ] democrats have to
have notes to say [ __ ] that's why
they're disingenuous he's looking down
at his note cards here that's why he's
got the phone you know down on his lap
because he's got the [ __ ] notes down
on his lap and he's looking at the notes
he can't [ __ ] handle just to talk out
loud into a microphone in front of a
camera it ain't that hard you little
[ __ ]
it really isn't i do it every day for
two hours and don jr you're definitely
[ __ ] welcome to come on this show you
[ __ ] don't apologize to these
people don't apologize don't bend the
knee that is just the stepping stone for
them to cancel you forever
don't give up on this one folks uh free
speech freedom there's way too much at
stake keep threatening them keep
threatening them and don't give up
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
is [ __ ] bonehead
you need to lay off the [ __ ] crank
dude
lay off the [ __ ] crank um i said
alpha cux entered the chat here's a
video from midas touch um where uh you
you remember dr [ __ ] you remember dr
dr dum [ __ ]
dr [ __ ] from
from tucker car excuse me joe rogan
tucker carlson what the [ __ ] the
difference at this point
uh
you remember dr [ __ ] here from joe
rogan's show where he was talking about
mass formation psychosis and he was
trying to project it on to the left
about the vaccine you [ __ ] idiots i
played this a while back i might go find
it and we'll watch dr dum buck say that
[ __ ] again but here dr [ __ ] this guy
claims he [ __ ] invented the vaccine
he didn't invent the vaccine
he didn't invent the vaccine
this [ __ ] guy he's so butt hurt that
everyone else took credit for the little
bit of [ __ ] smidge work that he may
have done 30 years ago that may have led
to the development of the vaccine we
have today and he ain't making money off
of it and he's [ __ ] butthurt so he's
running around with all these fascists
doing his fascist media tour
and it comes out apparently that the
group that made this little attack
cropped clip
that resulted they did that
you're such a bunch of dumb [ __ ]
if you were listening for a half a
[ __ ] second half a [ __ ] second
like just pluck your [ __ ] head out of
your ass for two seconds that [ __ ]
clip that patriot takes posted was made
by alex jones
alex jones is the one who produced the
clan it's not it's not [ __ ] it's not
hidden it's not secret alex jones did it
on his [ __ ] show
on his show on infowars alex jones is
the one who released that [ __ ] that
clip of joe rogan saying the n word over
and over and over and over again and
also the clip of joe rogan talking about
how
black people are playing as the apes or
when he went to playing whatever the
that racist [ __ ] he was saying you
[ __ ] idiots
us and we're supposed to take this guy
dr dumpfuck seriously about the vaccine
we're supposed to listen to him and
believe him about a vaccine and he can't
even get the [ __ ] facts straight that
the goddamn clip was alex jones
midas touch has nothing to do with that
[ __ ] clip the only thing minus dutch
or patriot takes has to do with that
clip is holding these [ __ ] idiots
accountable by publishing [ __ ] that's
already been published
because here's the fact of the matter
it's not like alex jones even secretly
recorded joe rogan saying this [ __ ] it
ain't like alex jones was in the
conversation with joe rogan and they
were pitching back the n-word back and
forth and alex jones is like ha ha i'll
get you i'll clip up this private
conversation that i recorded no it was
[ __ ] it was it was stand-up material
it was podcast material that joe rogan
had said recorded and published
he edited it to be published that way
and [ __ ] alex jones just took the
clips of him saying the n word and put
it in an order
and then patriot takes is like oh well
that [ __ ] is relevant as [ __ ] right
now because joe rogan's in the news and
patriot takes post it to twitter and
blow and behold midas touch retweets it
and here we are this doctor [ __ ]
can't figure this out
second hostage video on facebook
fascinating first one was on instagram
uh if i go to facebook
oh oh why why you go to face it's
instagram and facebook are the same
[ __ ] thing you dumb [ __ ] how
the f how in the [ __ ]
don't they know this
how don't they know this
how is it even how are they how the [ __ ]
are we so [ __ ] stupid
they they're telling us to do our own
research on facebook go to facebook and
do your own research to figure out if
instagram is part of facebook get the
[ __ ] out of here um
uh
was was this uh
left wing super pac
um that is uh
a mic the left wing super pac
left as if a super pac can only be right
wing
is uh uh midas
light or
touch yeah minus touch minus light ah
see that see you see what they're doing
there right
it's the same thing that dave portnoy
did in their little conversation with
ben mizellis
right dave portnoy knew who ben my
zealous was
and the reason why dayport know i knew
who ben myself was because he was you
know that [ __ ] [ __ ] he does he's like
you god down there in the left you know
there were all four on the screen and
dave tried to make it act like he didn't
know who the [ __ ] ben mizelis was
gay portnoy knows who ben my zealous was
is because dave portnoy [ __ ] hates
colin kaepernick
and if you know anything recently in the
news about colin kaepernick you know
that ben my zelis is not only his
business partner but he's his good
friend and his lawyer his attorney
and if dave portnoy knew anything about
that he would shut his [ __ ] mouth
quickly but here we have dr [ __ ]
playing like they don't know their name
let's play it again
yeah minus touch
light herbs
yeah minus touch there it is minus touch
now listen to what he says after this
because this is fantastic um with a
misspelling of midas says no it's not a
misspelling of midas go look it up you
[ __ ] idiot just go google it go
google go google midas see the minus
touch the lubin tune that you're talking
about that's named after a family of
midas and that's how they spell it and
that was the misspelling you people
really are [ __ ] dumb to tell us to do
on research you can't take five [ __ ]
minutes jesus christ
and this is this is it's
on a channel called fox news
apparently they listen to what he says
there
the misspelling
apparently they want to have his as if
it was media um and he's saying they're
misspelling it so it looks like media
like this is the conspiracy theory that
the mizellas brothers
went and made sure to spell midas touch
correctly right the actual way to spell
it when you're talking about midas
and
and and they're spelling it like media
so they can like hypnose you into
becoming part of the cabal or some [ __ ]
these people really are [ __ ] up and uh
they're lost apparently they want to
have his head on the wall because it's
going to help them with future
fundraising
what what in the [ __ ] would joe rogan
being canceled
help midas touch with fundraising
why the [ __ ] would that help them
who who who in the world wouldn't want
if you're gonna fundraise off joe rogan
why wouldn't you want that idiot saying
stupid [ __ ] into the microphone every
day
and i believe that's what minus touch
said that's what brett said we want to
compete with his ideas we want to
compete with him
that's how you raise money you don't
raise money by getting rid of them all
together and them not being able to
[ __ ] say anything so you can't
fundraise off of it
this is this is [ __ ] politics 101
folks
this is what the right wing always does
jesus christ matt gatz and marjory
taylor green are raising trying to raise
money every day to make donald trump the
speaker of the house
um and it it has nothing to do with
vaccines it has nothing to do with
meteor me and peter mccullough and the
proof of that in the pudding is if they
really cared about the vaccine story uh
then they the [ __ ] the clip has
nothing what are you talking about you
started with talking about the clips
where he's saying the n word now you're
talking about the vaccine
which is it which is it to you dumb
[ __ ] is it about the [ __ ]
clip about the next or is it about the
vaccines the [ __ ] misinformation he's
been spreading about the vaccines or is
it about the clip of him saying the n
word make up your [ __ ] minds he would
have hit bobby who also has a spotify
channel
but nothing yeah this was about taking
out rogan yep that's your thing i think
rogan was perceived as a threat on
multiple levels
it wasn't just that he was a good trophy
oh he's a threat he's such a threat
to them to midas touch
who has 700 000 followers
on twitter and several hundred thousand
on youtube and facebook and the
instagram oh it's such a threat threat
to what
what are you what are you [ __ ]
talking about again if joe rogan is a
fundraising tool for midas touch why
would they want to silence him get the
[ __ ] out of here to hang on your wall if
you want to gin up more capital for your
hollywood-based super pac
hollywood base you hear that midas
mighty do you guys all live in hollywood
sounds like you all live in hollywood
i mean there's no midas touch
in texas none of them in florida surely
there's none of them in the midwest at
all i would i would imagine that they
couldn't even put a meet-up together
anywhere in those states
all
all the minus money every single one of
them are either or either are either
bots
or they live in hollywood apparently
according to dr [ __ ] here who can't
figure out how midas touch is actually
spelled
that's what we're dealing with here um
was it three brothers i think that
general that are about this
but what joe did wrong
was this appeasement you cannot do that
with these people and that's the lesson
see and that's the best part um because
these [ __ ] are turning on them right
they're turning on them they're [ __ ]
turning on him because and i seen this
come and i said the other day when he he
should have done two things two things
for his audience there's only two things
he should have done
and those two things those two [ __ ]
things was either to say a nothing
not a goddamn thing don't apologize or
come out and say [ __ ] you i'm a comedian
i get to say whatever the [ __ ] i want to
say and if you don't like it [ __ ] you
that's what he should have said but he
didn't he didn't that's why rogan's in
trouble here that's why
when when dwayne the rock johnson
changed his position on the how he was
supporting rogan and why he was
supporting rogan when he changed his
position it changed everything the
[ __ ] patriot takes video
because patriot takes post of that and
because it went viral because they
posted that and because because don
winslow pointed out to the rock because
that's what happened
that's what happened
patriot takes took the video that alex
jones produced on infowars of clips that
joe rogan published of his [ __ ]
podcast
patriot takes didn't posted it midas
touch retweeted it don winslow seen the
[ __ ] video and don winslow
took the quote tweet of the [ __ ] tape
that patriot takes posted and tagged the
rock in it and called him out
and the rock seen it because don winslow
is the one who who [ __ ] tagged him
and that's when
dwayne the rock johnson who has a much
bigger [ __ ] microphone than joe rogan
way bigger microphone than joe rogan and
tucker carlson will ever [ __ ] dream
of
the rockets that's the microphone he's
got
and when the rock did what he did
because don winslow called him out
on his stance of joe rogan and the rock
did the classy [ __ ] thing and
actually did the right thing the right
apology
and made amends for what he had said and
how he may may have put himself in a
position that wasn't the correct one
that he wanted to be in with the
microphone that he has
that's when joe rogan made the apology
it wasn't about the [ __ ] video it was
about that dwayne the rock johnson seed
in the [ __ ] video
and he called him out on it
that's the point
that's what
happened and these dumb bucks
and dr [ __ ] here
leslie jones posted this video from from
tick tock
and it's very significant
it's very significant and the reason why
it's significant is because it destroys
all the anti-backs arguments
all all these [ __ ]
fragile white males these anti-vaxxers
these [ __ ] trump up and maga types
these stoolies
that loved loved dave portnoy that
[ __ ] alpha cuck
these [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
here here is what here is what joe
rogan's stance was on vaccines
here it is just pay attention back in
march of 2020
i'm going to say something that is going
to make one most of you want to
swipe past this but then i'll explain
the last 90 seconds
of this video is going to be a clip from
the joe rogan show
wait
wait
on march 10th 2020 roughly three four
days befo well i'm out in san francisco
that was three or four days before
everything out here shut down for covid
joe rogan interviewed a doctor uh
a disease expert infectious disease
epidemiology a guy named michael
osterholm
uh who's i think he's from uh works out
in minnesota
and he's awesome he's
he's a straight shooter and he tells it
like it is
and
rogan had him on and and he interviewed
him
uh and this is when osterholm was like
this is gonna be bad there's gonna be
like 600 000 dead americans and
everybody lost their [ __ ] minds
um but the clip that i'm going to tag on
to the end of this
is joe rogan talking about how amazing
miraculous and valuable vaccines are it
was less than two years ago
he's lost his mind with all that spotify
money
no so that's what we need to do here we
need to just have straight talk don't
tell them it's low risk that's like the
hurricane okay you know i would be
really bad at you if i thought you were
a hurricane forecaster and you knew this
was coming but you kept telling me oh
it's low risk don't worry about it right
yeah once it hit yeah so that's what we
need to do today is just say this is
going to be challenging
and we're going to get through it though
we are going to get through it i hope
this wakes people up to the value of
vaccines too there's so many wackos out
there that think that vaccines
are you know a scam or they're dangerous
or it's
there's so many people out there that
won't vaccinate their children i know
and that's one you know one of your best
shows here was peter hotels yeah he's a
dear friend of mine he's a i do too he's
a dear friend of mine as you and you
know he is one of the champions out
there on this very issue i couldn't
agree with you more i think that's
really an important point that you know
we got to get this idea these vaccines
can be life-saving if we had one right
now think how different the situation
would be and we're in right thank you
for what you do say about vaccines
because people listen to you and we need
every positive voice because we have so
many crazy voices out there right now
that are so
paranoid and
delusional and they want it all to be a
conspiracy there's been an amazing
medical innovation
in in human culture and that's vaccines
it's amazing what it's done and have
there been adverse re effects on people
of course everything everything that
people do there's some people are going
to react in a bad way it doesn't mean
it's not a positive thing
okay so leslie jones is the one who
posted this right and on her
and it might be someone else that it
came from it is no it came from her
leslie jones posted this
from her media studio she took this
video off tic-tac she says just want to
leave this he right here hmm
leslie jones is a comedian
she understands
she understands the comedy of things
right
she knows that joe rogan's not doing
comedy and i've been saying that when
he's on his podcast talking about
vaccines just like he's talking about
his [ __ ] clip right here
he's not doing comedy this is not comedy
folks
that's not what this is
it's not
it won't be it never will be
so to [ __ ] hide behind the guise of
comedy is [ __ ] it's ridiculous
laughable at best no pun intended
but this [ __ ] guy continues to hide
behind comedy when he's trying to do
serious commentary and here's the thing
the reason why joe rogan can switch his
position from this position two years
ago to his position now is because his
audience is a bunch of [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] and they want the dribble whatever
the dribble is they want the dribble
whatever it may be tomorrow it'll be
something different
right now it's the anti we gotta take
ivermectin
two years ago this saying this guy is
saying joe rogan is saying hey vaccines
are one of the best things that humans
have ever done
and then he does a video
after he gets cold like you don't need
it you don't need a vaccine when you're
healthy and you have all these immune
systems and you drink your own piss and
eat horse paste
he's a [ __ ] joke and should be
treated as such
and the problem is is that joe rogan
gained such serious
serious
people taking him seriously is because
he would have serious people on his
podcast
and he would never distinguish the
difference between commentary and comedy
yes he's a stand-up comedian
he's an okay one shitty most of the time
especially when he's spewing racist [ __ ]
on stage intentionally
and recording it and publishing it for
all to see
but he's not always doing comedy
this what he's doing right here when
he's talking about vaccines is not
comedy
and when he brings dr dumpbuck on like
he did uh several weeks ago to talk
about how vaccines bad after two years
of bringing a real doctor on who knows
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
they don't have some kind of [ __ ]
vendetta against the vaccine industry
speaks the truth about vaccines health
and science and joe rogan placates to
him joe rogan is going to placate to
whoever's in front of him because he's a
[ __ ] joke
he's a [ __ ] joke
but it's not comedy and it isn't and it
isn't funny sometimes
so
i guess i'll get off my joe rogan
soapbox here let's take a quick break
we'll be back right after this
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopes mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop left you
customized from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew feed the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to joe
thanks for sticking with us through the
break
who else is [ __ ] sick of this goddamn
joe rogan story
just completely [ __ ] sick of it i
really am i'm sick of [ __ ] talking
about it it doesn't seem like it but
jesus [ __ ] christ why do we have to
keep going here with this stupid [ __ ]
these dumb [ __ ] just keep keep
on and keep on and keep on with the dumb
stupid [ __ ] they can't [ __ ] stop they
can't [ __ ] stop
but here we are i think it's gonna die
out this week i think it'll die out this
week and here's why i think so is that i
think joe rogan is gonna be forced to
change his content uh spotify has
probably already went to him and said
hey
hey the whole misinformation thing on
the vaccines you need to not be doing
that [ __ ] do something else have
comedians on and don't bring up [ __ ]
covet dumb [ __ ] do comedy for a
little bit talk about the ufc
talk about that kind of [ __ ] i think his
content is going to change that's how
he's going to wiggle his way out of this
and what i mean wiggle his way out of
this is keep his show at spotify because
spotify is profiting off of this and
that's the other big story about this
thing that you know started to happen in
the beginning but it worked its way down
to joe rogan is a [ __ ] joke
he's a buffoon he's just a jester for
these [ __ ] fragile white males that's
all he is
it's all he is
spotify doesn't give a [ __ ] about rogan
he they don't they only care about his
[ __ ] audience and what they want to
do is make sure that they can [ __ ]
pump the racist message to the people
who will buy it that's it they want to
sell advertising around a [ __ ]
message that that these people will
[ __ ] buy the advertising that's what
it is
it has nothing to do with rogan he just
had the audience already that they could
just buy it
okay let's go back to the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends here
let's see what else is going on let's
see what else is going on what else did
we have to go through today we had bob
woodward we had omarosa we did that uh
maggie haberman went there flush gate we
talked about the flush gate and the
trucker's convoy i don't even know if
we're going to go there uh al franken is
in the news i guess he's considering
running maybe we'll go do the al franken
thing
maggie's still trending there friday
thoughts is there any other new news
that we while we've been on the air for
two hours we are
we are 35 minutes into the second hour
so it's possible that there were some
news obama08 what's this [ __ ]
what's this [ __ ] here
uh looks like barack obama tweeted
something if you worked as an organizer
on the campaign or volunteered
volunteered in your community i'd love
to hear your stories
from the day using hashtag obama08 so it
looks like uh and president barack obama
a classy ex-president is um tweeting
about um
people to get get some campaign stories
so it looks like that's what's it looks
like that's what's going on people are
going to be posting pictures you're
going to see a lot of obama
08 stuff happening the young obama you
know before he was president
and not the not the obama nowadays
uh which is much older you know this is
what happened when they become president
dude did something to change here and
looks like the timeline change let's
refresh it's always with the with the
news like this there's like a
five-second news cycle
right
i'm still surprised that joe rogan has
lasted this long in the news
now spotify hasn't liked it but maybe he
does
dude the trump white house is trending
because they were flushing [ __ ] down the
toilet
kim jong-un
is trending now
and just because you know
the former guy wants to
uh continue his love interest
with kim jong-un oh i knew i knew mayo
would be on it mayo are you in here
i knew mayo would be on it
donald trump has been sexting
[Laughter]
kim jong-un
since he left office oh my god
mayo
she is after all of our hearts she
really is
one of the best accounts
ever
ever
on political twitter you know what i'm
gonna go to her page because there is
some there's some news there's some mayo
news
i gotta announce some mayo news
everybody
uh if you didn't see it of course it's
probably all the way down our feed
um madison cawthorne actually tweeted at
her did you guys see this
did you see this [ __ ] come on you had to
have seen this
well let's see if only we could flush
donald trump down the toilet yeah yeah
if only it would flush like 15 times i
keep flushing and flushing and flushing
and flushing get rid of that
[ __ ] okay let's see
dude
where is it where is it you know what
here we'll find it here
i think i got it out
there it is
here we go okay here's the here's the
mayo news mail made the news all right
mail made the news
mail let's make it bigger we gotta
announce this news here this is
important stuff
this is important stuff here
mayo tweeted madison cawthorne is having
a very bad day i didn't even retweet
this what the hell is wrong with me
okay i'm sorry we'll get we'll take care
of this
give her credit here he's having a very
bad day
very bad day
and this [ __ ]
i'm having a great day
i'm having a great day
he tweets at her
um so
mayo has entered the chat
uh your tweet sucks by the way
some people call him sittler i don't
know i'm not gonna call him that but
some people call him sittler i don't
know if you guys have heard that before
so whatever you do don't whatever you do
don't do that because apparently it may
be offensive to him
um
don't call him sittler but i've heard
people call him hitler
she says
i don't believe you
[Laughter]
oh my god
so mayo has entered the news uh by
madison cawthorne
uh
quote tweeting her that he's having a
great day thanks mayo for making the
news okay let's see where were we at i'm
sorry i got distracted mary trump is now
trending what's mary trump trending
about
is it about her book is it about how she
said something oh here we go palmer
report everyone hates the palmer report
oh there's such fake news give given how
many people sat on crucial information
critical information about trump's
crimes so they could cash in later with
a book deal michael cohen and mary trump
deserve all the more credit for putting
the information out there at the time
it was needed and worrying about the
book later
you know i i do have to that is a good
point
like they didn't just sit on this stuff
um you know michael cohen definitely
could have sat on this like for sure
mary trump absolutely but michael cohen
for sure because apparently the
documents that omarosa is talking about
is documents that he was about with
michael cohen
uh let's see
um
of course mary has a podcast did you
guys know that uh she's got a podcast
let's see is there something else is
there actually merry news or is this
just because
um you know
she basically exposed him
that's january 24th that's an old piece
of news
oh my god
can you imagine can you imagine some
creepy guy like this being president
united states
what the hell
i'm just saying
i'm just saying
could be
disgusting
if for all you listening on the on the
audio version this is a this is a photo
of what looks like donald trump
molesting ivanka okay
[Music]
where else what else do we have let's go
back
okay so mary trump is twin trending um
kim jong-un that's the one we want to go
into surely there's some good uh
photoshop pictures in here there's gotta
be some good photoshops in this one
there's gotta be oh here we go
here's a good one
[Laughter]
don't step on the cheeseburger for all
the audience listen out there it looks
like a masked mou
mouse trap with a cheeseburger on it
where kim jong-un is inviting donald
trump to step on of course we remember
the the the picture of this dumb [ __ ]
going and placating to this [ __ ]
murderous dictator
you [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] idiot
yeah kim jungling
we're 42 minutes into the into the
second hour here
oh
is there any what else would do we want
to talk about
oh the trucker envoy should we do the
trucker envoy
should we do that i think we should we
should go look at that news someone was
telling me the other day hey you gotta
go look at this news
hey you gotta go look at this news
did you guys know i was on another
podcast last night it's called dig on
america it's on my timeline
uh it's it's a
three guys that have a podcast they talk
about democracy and i was on there with
ray reid he's running in missouri second
i seen my search bar up there reminding
me of it
i was on that show last night you should
go check it out it's in the timeline
there
um here's the
let's see
mark says
republicans with a q this is part where
you start passing laws so that people
can just drive through the protesters
and kill them without being charged
right
or is that just for black people damn
mark not holding a punch today at all
not [ __ ] one
[ __ ] to give
um you know this this is this is the
[ __ ] they love they love blocking
traffic when it's them and it benefits
their narrative
they love it but it is not it is not
good
when when you know like black people do
it to protest you know police brutality
and [ __ ] you know men being black men
being killed but when they block a
bridge and step up a bridge it's great
for them
now you know this is this is all [ __ ]
drummed up [ __ ]
right in this blockade and blocking this
bridge
i mean this is all drummed up [ __ ] uh
it'll it'll fade away eventually
because they can't withstand uh this
this nonsense for very long i mean these
people will have to eventually go make
money
like they can't you know they can't do
this for forever
um
truckers convoy course you know the
problem with some of these hashtags like
this like this [ __ ] hashtag
we need to go take over this [ __ ]
hashtag because this [ __ ] thread is
stuff for a bunch of [ __ ] lies and
[ __ ] just absolute nonsense about
this
and somehow this is [ __ ] great and
it's patriotic and it's american this is
canadian truckers american money has
american dark
right-wing money has convinced a bunch
you know dozens of truckers to take
their trucks and park them on a bridge
to block commerce which they claim to be
for free market
let the free market decide we'll let the
free market decide if you don't want to
[ __ ] comply with requirements of
vaccines and masks well then don't be a
[ __ ] trucker
don't be a [ __ ] trucker go do
something else that doesn't require you
dumb [ __ ]
okay i can't i
can't even do it anymore
uh uh what the other subject we wanted
to touch on
was moscow um you guys know
um the let's see if we can
find that thread
all this stuff was trending and it fell
off you know that that's how it happens
sometimes with this five second news
cycle
it seemed like there was some news
um
it's like
there's some news from ukraine
um it seems like the ukrainians are
trying to to downplay what's happening
[ __ ] i gotta i can't i can't resist
i can't resist did you see this this
video or at the picture
this is what the picture kind of looks
like with putin putin is [ __ ]
terrified of the virus by the way like
he is [ __ ] terrified of it he won't
come near anyone
like he like when he's in the same room
as someone you are not allowed to get
within like 20 feet of that [ __ ]
and this is more evidence of it and how
[ __ ] weak and scared this guy is
right like i mean the virus is a serious
thing but you'd think putin would be
vaccinated right but he is completely
[ __ ] terrified of this virus
he won't even sit
at at a table where someone's not like
40 feet away from but let's watch the
video
um for all of you listening out there
it's putin on one end of this 40-foot
table
and it's like a teeter-totter here it's
hilarious
oh thank you for the laugh
oh my god
[Music]
but uh he's terrified of the virus
and you know what's funny is all these
right-wingers these tucker carlson types
think he's so [ __ ] tough like yo he's
a tough guy he's such a badass
oh he's he's so [ __ ] tough
he won't come within 12 feet of anybody
like he's so [ __ ] scared of the virus
let's just do this let's do this maybe
we'll show you some pictures here putin
putin
putin
let's see uh
dude there's the picture sheldon
whitehouse says this is actually how
putin meets with people
look at this
[ __ ] joker
he's so tough oh my putin oh my putin's
so tough we love we love authoritarian
dictators so much
we love them
thanks thanks splatty daddy oh you're
keen of the dog is
uh tucker carlson has announced vladimir
putin has adopted him
oh tucker loves [ __ ] putin [ __ ]
loves him
putin's puppy i did a video about this
once
let's see
i'd seen a picture the other day where
he was meeting with someone here you go
here's another one
here is macron
and putin in the same room
look out they're standing next to each
other this has got to be at least 25
feet apart
at least 25 feet apart and this is all
for
[ __ ] um
uh
coveted demands because he's [ __ ]
terrified
of this virus
he's terrified of it he's [ __ ] weak
he's a little [ __ ]
like dude if you're vaccinated and you
wear a mask you really ain't got [ __ ] to
worry about
and you i mean i mean yeah you can still
get sick but i mean
really honestly unless you got you know
some really bad conditions
you're gonna be all right you just you
just got to take the precautions you
know
um but he's so weak he can't even do
that that's right putin's weak he's
[ __ ] weak
let's see um
there's another picture
let's see
trying to find
the picture
of him standing at a distance with
someone else but yeah
he didn't like this virus putin's weak
putin's week we're 50 minutes into the
hour let's see what other topic that we
had to touch on bob woodward was the
other one in al franken let's go to the
al franken thread
i want to do the al franken thread
as you guys know al franken um
quit and he resigned his seat to the
senate
um after a scandal that was manufactured
by the sean hannity show
um and if you don't believe me you can
go look at the reports
and he was he there was a picture that
was circulated of him posing with
another comedian
um
where they sh he seemed to be grabbing
her breasts the the the photographer who
actually took the picture confirmed at
that time that it was a joke it was a
stage joke
but occupied well let me see if i can
zoom it in correctly occupy democrat
says breaking news al franken's
announced that he is
tempted is tempted quote unquote to run
for his old senate seat again reveals
that he regrets having resigned over a
non-scandal
so al franken um regrets resigning
um
after democrats pushed him out now that
that's that's what we do sometimes when
we hold people accountable no matter who
they are
is sometimes there's jumping to
conclusions that happens especially when
there's false information that is
circulated and reported on um you know
the media loves this type of stuff let's
see if we can find is there a [ __ ]
video of him saying this
do you guys know there's our video let's
go to the videos videos let's see if
there's videos of him saying this
i don't know if he said this on his
because he's got a show he's got a
podcast i know if he said this on his
show
or if he
it looks like he may have said it on his
show looks like youtube here has got it
and is there a clip of it on here
someone needs to pull this clip and
throw it up on twitter why the [ __ ]
ain't this clip on twitter
who has not ripped this thing off from
youtube and put it on twitter yet it's
ridiculous ridiculous
uh this is from february 2nd that's
probably not it
what is he talking about there yeah he's
talking about the whoopi goldberg thing
and we don't want to hear about that we
that's that's that that's more than five
seconds ago i want the clip of him
saying that he's gonna return let's see
if this will
[Music]
and a reminder to our audience we want
this stranger this is like this is like
28 minutes long
time in
or uh in florida
she basically said that she didn't think
the
you know the holocaust was about race
okay so i'm not gonna be able to find it
because this thing's like a 28 minute
video god damn it
someone go cut this thing go find that
clip put the clip on the internet and
tag it al franken or i will or i will
um it looks like mj or is this what's
this a quote from mj categorically
untrue and simply made up by a reporter
in order to get publicity for her mostly
fictitious book is that uh is that a
quote
from al franken himself
because if you remember this story
he was on the usa uso tour with this
person um there also was the story about
him kissing her in a rehearsal
and it later came out and there was
video
prior to the day that the day that she
said that
oh you're talking about the cheeto dust
mobster's statement oh i'm i'm missing
the chat here i'm sorry i'm very sorry
um but uh um you remember the al franken
story the the person who accused him of
touching her when she was passed out in
the chair of course the photographer
confirms that it was a bit and then it
was staged like she pretended she was
passed out and now franken made the joke
and they took the picture of it now
while they were touring with the uso and
she also accused him of of you know
kissing her during rehearsal
inappropriately but they actually um
there was video of it before
before
before the the
date that she said
um that
the actual uso and the actual bit that
they were doing like the bit that they
were doing was exactly what they would
have rehearsed like they would have
rehearsed that that bit but there was
evident video evidence of of them doing
the bit several years before
um so it kind of you know it it was all
[ __ ] um and sean hannity is the one
that really and fox news is the one that
pushed that story
and yoda says you can yeah and you sent
me something here let me
something you talking about the um the
don jr thing
the john donny jr thing yeah you're
editing pictures go post that and i'll
show it
if you got it in a post
um
oh
mj you sent me a new york times post
let's uh let's go to that that seems
significant here now we've got uh five
minutes left in the hour
let's see
mj's on top of it here thank you mj
sometimes i don't see the news while i'm
doing the show
breaking news this is about two hours
old new york times is reporting january
6 investigators have found gaps in the
white house
and the white house phone records during
the capital riot
when they when they know donald trump is
making calls
um i'm not sure this is the headline as
someone read this article um it looks
like to me someone's hiding phone
records you know this seems really
[ __ ] significant
it seems really significant that there's
missing phone call records during the
time of the ride like maybe he would be
calling someone
i don't know i'm just saying that um
everyone keeps whining and complaining
about how this investigation is moving
and if you're if you're not paying
attention
if you're not paying attention
this investigation is moving in places
we never [ __ ] dreamed of did you ever
[ __ ] dream
a year ago
during this time right after right after
joe biden has taken office we just they
just impeached donald trump twice
they didn't they didn't remove him he's
a disgraced
two-time impeach piece of [ __ ] that had
to move down to mar-a-lago and take 15
boxes worth of [ __ ] with him so that he
doesn't get caught
okay
and then
then then what we have to do
then what we have to do is talk about
how he was eating [ __ ] documents and
flushing them down i said do you think
we would even be close to here
think about this
and now now we now we're finding out
that phone records from january 6 are
being hidden so that no one knows who he
was calling during the [ __ ]
insurrection the cheeto death kangaroo
attempt
[ __ ] absolute craziness that we're
even here and yes
yes
yes
is it going to take some time but look
how far we've come we've gotten all the
way to the point to where we know that
the january 6 investigators are finding
gaps in the white house phone records
that they're trying to hide
during during the insurrection and what
pisses me off about this headline the
most
is the [ __ ] new york times calls it
the capital riot
it's a coup attempt
that's why they're hiding the phone
records you [ __ ] idiots
it's a coup attempt
they were trying to overthrow the
constitution of the united states
they wanted him to be dictator and king
the orange mussolini jesus are you not
following yet
it wasn't a riot
it was a coup attempt they used a riot
in an insurrection to add cover to what
they were trying to do in the eastman
memo the whole point was that we're
gonna find out that these [ __ ]
alternative these fraudulent alternative
slate of electors they wanted mike pence
to use those electors to crown donald
trump king to [ __ ]
all over the constitution just like they
smeared their [ __ ] all over our capitol
walls
it was a coup attempt otherwise it
wouldn't be hiding phone records if it
was about a [ __ ] riot
come on give me a [ __ ] break
get the [ __ ] out of here with that riot
[ __ ] new york times get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] you know what
frankly
because of that headline i'm gonna
retweet this
so everyone can see it but your [ __ ]
headline sucks so guess what your
[ __ ] tweet sucks
your tweet [ __ ] sucks new york times
let's see let's add something to this
i'm [ __ ] pissed off
learn
how to
spell
who
there you go
you [ __ ]
live tweeting you [ __ ] idiots it's
not a riot it's a [ __ ] coup it was a
coup attempt you dumb [ __ ]
all right we're 50 we're 59 minutes into
the hour i appreciate you guys joining
us today join us tomorrow don't forget
don't forget to go vote for bonehead of
the week
bone of the week
brian suave
uh forrest gump kevin mccarthy and jared
kushner
you can go to at tony michael's pod or
the tony michaels
follow us there you can follow
me the tony michaels and follow gabe at
i am gabe sanchez
go vote for bonehead of the week so week
because we're going to do that tomorrow
in the second hour
you know every friday we do that um one
more thing before i go
because it looks like um uh let's see
yeah i want to show this yoda send it to
me hang on yuda i'll give you your do
here and then and then we'll cut out
here
uh we'll end we'll end on this note
here is uh here's the don jr there's
something in the background here looks
like i don't know what is that yo is
that is that um it looks i it looks
funny it looks funny and you guys i'll
i'll retweet this
and you guys can go take a look and see
what yoda's got here thank you yoda for
your picture
[Music]
we'll end on that note tomorrow remember
noon eastern 11 central right here
youtube twitter twitch we'll do the
shitless roundup in the first hour bone
end of the week in the second hour happy
thursday we'll see you tomorrow on
friday noon eastern
don't
let your meat loaf
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born had asked me